[Music]
this is a trip China hopes will end war
in Ukraine but it's a delicate mission
for Chinese president XI jamping
she has repeatedly said his country is
neutral in the conflict but he is widely
seen as a key Alliance and supporter of
Russian President Vladimir Putin
China values the friendship between
China and Russia this has historical
logic because we are neighbors and two
large countries we're also strategic
Partners such a position determines that
we have a very close relationship
last month China presented a peace plan
to end the war in Ukraine but while it
calls for an end to unilateral sanctions
against Russia and a ceasefire it makes
no mention of Russian troops withdrawing
from Ukrainian territory
President Vladimir Putin said Russia is
open to a political and diplomatic
solution
we have considered your proposals for
settlement of the Ukraine crisis of
course we will have an opportunity to
discuss this we know that you are basing
this or principle of fairness and
upholding the principle of the
international law indivisible security
for all countries you also know that
we're always open to negotiations we'll
discuss all these issues including your
initiative
following his trip to Moscow president
gjamping is likely to speak with
Ukrainian leader Vladimir zielinski for
the first time since the start of the
war
but Ukraine has rejected calls for a
ceasefire while its territory is
occupied by Russian forces
Beijing also faces another challenge
convincing Western leaders Who Remain
largely skeptical of its peace plan
the United States said it was designed
to deflect attention from China's
support for Putin Washington has
recently disclosed intelligence that
China was considering sending secret
shipments of weapons to Russia and if
that happens the U.S warns it may impose
economic sanctions on Beijing
Al Jazeera
journalist Julius
has more on the meeting from Moscow
we know that the informal meeting
between the Russian and Chinese leaders
have finished during the meeting we
heard from Vladimir Putin as saying that
he had carefully read China's peace plan
for a Ukrainian settlement and we also
know that the Russian president said
that beijing's plan could be discussed
Russia is always open to the negotiation
process that was according to the
Russian president so probably as far as
we know that the Chinese peaceful plan
was not quite you know endorsed by
Ukraine and the Western countries so
probably that plan will be a little bit
tweaked or adjusted in the nearest
Future probably tomorrow because
tomorrow is the the most important day
of this visit
and here now is Katrina you with the
view from Beijing
China's trying to capitalize
momentum of its successful brokering of
peace between Saudi Arabia and Iran and
XI Japan is really looking at this visit
other than strengthening his ties with
Vladimir Putin as an opportunity to
project China as a global power as a
peacemaker Xi Jinping wants to get the
attention particularly of countries
perhaps in the developing world who
might be a bit tired of seeing the US
constantly as a leader and might be more
open to China as an alternative now
we've seen in these opening shots
there's pleasantries and this chatting
between Vladimir Putin and Xi Jinping I
think when it comes to geopolitics we
can't underestimate the importance of
the strong personal Rapport between
these two leaders ten years ago more
than 10 years ago now when President Xi
Jinping became the leader of China
Russia was the first country he visited
and he said at the time that he was
heralding a new chapter in Moscow
Beijing ties and now we've had the two
leaders meet more than 40 times this is
president XI jinping's lifetime in
Moscow Vladimir Putin last time I made a
ice cream birthday cake for president XI
Jin pinkies Putin himself has said that
Xi Jinping is the only state leader that
he celebrated his own birthday with and
I think what really crucially ties these
two together it's not just the fact that
they're from Russia and China because
those two countries have had really
complicated histories what I think is
most important here is this these these
two leaders are the heads of
authoritarian countries they have a
strong man style leadership they're both
figured out ways to sort of manipulate
the system so that they can be leaders
basically for the rest of their lives
and the important thing that we need to
watch out is members of the
International Community that these two
share a world view and that is that they
don't believe that the world should be
led by the Us and other Western
democracy they don't think that kind of
World Order suits them and that it suits
other country it was basically they
would like to see their own countries
their own style of governance or their
own systems of governance become more
prominent